let me ask you all a question
how much weapons-grade nuclear material
do you think it would take to level a
city the size of San Francisco how many
of you think it would be an amount about
the size of this suitcase okay and how
about this mini bus all right
well actually under the right
circumstances an amount of highly
enriched uranium about the size of your
morning latte would be enough to kill a
hundred thousand people instantly
hundreds of thousands of others would
become horribly ill and parts of the
city would be uninhabitable for years if
not for decades but you can forget that
nuclear latte because today's nuclear
weapons are hundreds of times more
powerful even than those we dropped on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and even a
limited nuclear war involving say tens
of nuclear weapons could lead to the end
of all life on the planet so it's really
important that you know that right now
we have over 15,000 nuclear weapons in
the hands of nine nations and if you
live in a city or near a military
facility one is likely pointed right at
you in fact if you live in any of the
rural areas where nuclear weapons are
stored globally one is likely pointed at
you about 1800 of these weapons are on
high alert which means they can be
launched within 15 minutes of a
presidential command so I know this is a
bummer of an issue and maybe you have
that what was it psychic fatigue that we
heard about a little bit earlier so I'm
gonna switch gears for just a second and
I'm gonna talk about my imaginary friend
I like to think of as Jasmine just for a
moment Jasmine at the age of 25 is part
of a generation that is more politically
and socially engaged than anything we've
seen in 50 years she and her friends
think of themselves as change agents and
leaders and activists I think of them as
generation possible
they regularly protest about the issues
they care about but nuclear weapons are
not one of them which makes sense
because jasmine was born in 1991 at the
end of the Cold War so she didn't grow
up hearing a lot about nuclear weapons
she never had to Duck and Cover under
her desk at school for Jasmine a fallout
shelter is an app in the Android store
nuclear weapons help win games and that
is really a shame because right now we
need generation possible to help us make
some really important decisions about
nuclear weapons for instance will we
further reduce our nuclear arsenals
globally or will we spend billions maybe
a trillion dollars to modernize them so
they last throughout the 21st century so
that by the time jasmine is my age she's
talking to her children and maybe even
her grandchildren about the threat of
nuclear holocaust and if you're paying
any attention at all to cyber threats or
for instance if you've read about the
Stuxnet virus or for God's sake if
you've ever had an email account or a
yahoo account or a phone hacked you can
imagine the whole new world of the hurt
that could be triggered by modernization
in a period of cyber warfare now if
you're paying attention to the money a
trillion dollars could go a long way to
feeding and educating and employing
people all of which could reduce the
threat of nuclear war to begin with so
this is really crucial right now because
nuclear weapons they're vulnerable we
have solid evidence that terrorists are
trying to get a hold of them and just
this last spring when for retirees and
to taxi drivers were arrested in the
Republic of Georgia for trying to sell
nuclear materials for 200 million
dollars they demonstrated that the black
market for this stuff is alive and well
and it's really important because there
have been dozens of accidents involving
nuclear weapons and I bet most of us
have never heard anything about him just
here in the United States we've dropped
nuclear weapons on the Carolinas twice
in one case one of the bombs which fell
out of an airforce plane didn't detonate
because the nuclear core was stored
somewhere else on the plane in another
case the weapon did armed when it hit
the ground and five of the switches
designed to keep it from detonating
failed
luckily the sixth one didn't but if
that's not enough to get your attention
there was the 1995 black brandt incident
that's when Russian radar technicians
saw what they thought was a u.s. nuclear
missile streaking toward Russian
airspace it later turned out to be a
Norwegian rocket collecting data about
the Northern Lights but at that time
Russian president Boris Yeltsin came
within five minutes of launching a
full-scale retaliatory nuclear attack
against the United States so most of the
world's nuclear nations have committed
to getting rid of these weapons of mass
destruction but consider this the treaty
on the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons which is the most widely adopted
arms control treaty in history with 190
signatories sets no specific date by
which the world's nuclear-armed nations
will get rid of their nuclear weapons
now when John F Kennedy sent a man to
the moon and decided to bring him back
or decided to do both those things he
say hey whenever you guys get to it he
gave us a deadline he gave us a
challenge that would have been
incredible just a few years earlier and
with that challenge he inspired
scientists and marketers astronauts and
schoolteachers he gave us a vision but
with along with that vision he also
tried to give us and most people don't
know this either he tried to give us a
partner in the form of our fiercest cold
war rival the Soviet Union because part
of Kennedy's vision for the Apollo
program was that it be a cooperation not
a competition with the Soviets and
apparently Nikita Khruschev the Soviet
premier agreed but before that
cooperation could be realized Kennedy
was assassinated and that part of the
vision was deferred but the promise of
joint innovation between these two
nuclear superpowers wasn't totally
extinguished because in 1991 which is
the year that Jasmine was born and the
Soviet Union fell these two nations
engaged in a project that genuinely does
seem incredible today in the truest
sense of that word which is that the
u.s. sent cash to the Russians when they
needed it most to secure loose nuclear
materials and to employ out-of-work
nuclear scientists they worked alongside
American scientists to convert
weapons-grade uranium into the type of
fuel that can be used for nuclear power
instead they called it megatons to
megawatts so the result is that for over
20 years our two nations had a program
that meant that one in 10 light bulbs in
the United States was essentially fueled
by former Russian warheads so together
these two nations did something truly
audacious but the good news is that the
global community has the chance to do
something just as audacious today to get
rid of nuclear weapons and to end the
supply of the materials required to
produce them some experts tell me would
take 30 years it would take a
renaissance of sorts the kinds of
innovation that for better or worse
underpinned both the Manhattan Project
which gave rise to nuclear weapons and
the megatons to megawatts program it
would take design constraints these are
fundamental to creativity things like a
platform for international collaboration
a date certain which is a forcing
mechanism and a positive vision that
inspires action it would take us to 2045
now 2045 happens to be the 100th
anniversary of the birth of nuclear
weapons in the New Mexico desert but
it's also an important date for another
reason it's predicted to be the advent
of the singularity a new moment in human
development where the lines between
artificial intelligence and human
intelligence blur where computing and
consciousness become almost
indistinguishable and advanced
technologies help us solve the 21st
century's greatest problems hunger
energy poverty assuring in an era of
abundance and we all get to go to space
on our way to becoming a multiplanetary
species now the people who really
believe this vision are the first to say
they don't yet know precisely how we're
going to get there
but the values behind their vision and
the willingness to ask how might we have
inspired a generation of innovators
they're working backward from the
outcomes they want using the creative
problem-solving methods of collaborative
design they're busting through obstacles
they're redefining what we all consider
possible but here's the thing that
vision of abundance isn't compatible
with a world that still relies on a 20th
century nuclear doctrine called mutually
assured
destruction it has to be about building
the foundations for the 22nd century it
has to be about strategies for mutually
assured prosperity or at the very least
mutually assured survival now every day
I get to meet people who are real
pioneers in the field of nuclear threats
and as you can see many of them are
young women and they're doing fiercely
interesting stuff like marina Robinson
Snowden here who's developing new ways
better ways to detect nuclear warheads
which will help us overcome a critical
hurdle to international disarmament or
Melissa hanim who's using satellite
imaging to make sense of what's going on
around far-flung nuclear sites or we
have Beatrice Finn in Europe who has
been campaigning to make nuclear weapons
illegal in international courts of law
and just won a big victory at the UN
last week and yet and yet with all of
our talk in this culture about moonshots
too few members of generation possible
and those of us who mentor them are
taking on nuclear weapons it's as if
there's a taboo but I remember something
that Kennedy said that has really stuck
with me and that is something to the
effect that humans can be as big as the
solutions to all the problems we've
created no problem of human destiny he
said is beyond human beings I believe
that and I bet a lot of you here believe
that too and I know generation possible
believes it so it's time to commit to a
date let's end the nuclear weapons
chapter on the 100th anniversary of its
inception after all by 2045 we will have
held billions of people hostage to the
threat of nuclear annihilation
surely 100 years will have been enough
surely a century of economic development
and the development of military strategy
will have given us better ways to manage
global conflict
surely if ever there was a global moon
shot worth supporting this is it
now in the face of real threats for
instance North Korea's recent nuclear
weapons tests which fly in the face of
sanctions reasonable people disagree
about whether we should maintain some
number of nuclear weapons to deter
aggression but the question is what's
the magic number is it a thousand is it
a hundred ten and then we have to ask
who should be responsible for them I
think we can agree however that having
fifteen thousand of them represents a
greater global threat to Jasmin's
generation than a promise so it's time
that we make a promise of a world in
which we've broken the stranglehold that
nuclear weapons have on our imaginations
in which we invest in the creative
solutions that come from working
backward from a future we desperately
want rather than plotting forward from a
present that brings all of the mental
models and biases of the past with it
it's time that we pledged our resources
as leaders across the spectrum to work
on this old problem in new ways to ask
how might we how might we make good on a
promise of greater security for
Jasmine's generation in a world beyond
nuclear weapons I truly hope you will
join us thank you
thank you